so last night the state of Arkansas
executed Marcel Williams and Jack Harold
Jones on the same night this is the
first time since 2000 that there has
been a double execution and then in 2000
it was Texas they Texas was the state
that put two people to death last night
was not uneventful to say the least
there were complaints that the first
inmate to be put to death was actually
struggling in during the execution more
precisely they're saying that it looked
like as though he was gasping for air
because of that there was an initial
stay that was passed by the the judicial
system therein in Texas in Arkansas
rather but it didn't last they came back
very shortly 45 minutes later and and
put the next the next inmate to death
this is this is in light of governor ASA
Hutchinson's Republican governor of
Arkansas desire to put 8 men to death
before a prescription a cocktail that
they used in the execution expires at
the end of April and so in in almost an
unprecedented fashion he streamlined and
fast-tracked the execution of eight of
eight people their own death bro and so
far they've carried out I believe three
if not four of those executions Pat this
really goes into the conversation about
the death penalty in the first place why
is a civilized quote/unquote civilized
nation why are we still continue to to
pursue and execute people number one
pursue the death penalty and execute
people to be more precise but the number
two you look at the European Union you
can't even be a part of the European
Union if you are a nation that still
carries out the death penalty why in
America are we so obsessed with the
death penalty such that we're going to
fast track the execution of eight men
and one of whom had DNA evidence that
they were not even willing to review
yeah it's pretty insane the fact that
these drugs were set to expire and it's
not easy for them
to get more because they have to go to
Europe to do so and of course European
companies are not willing to do
something because they are not in
support of the death penalty themselves
and this also really just cuts at the
constitutionality of the death penalty
because if this is not cruel and unusual
punishment I don't know it is right and
and I think I think it's all levels and
measures of what you consider cruel and
unusual for some of the people that were
there some of the journalists that
actually reported that the first inmate
was gasping for air to them that was
cruel and unusual to the court system it
wasn't and the problem was that they had
a hard time it took them 45 minutes to
find the vein that they needed in the
neck of the first the first inmate
because he was so overweight and that
became arduous in itself so 45 minutes
for them sticking him 45 minutes to find
the place for the needle to go in like I
mean and this is the probably a bad
comparison but if it takes my
phlebotomist more than two tries to get
a needle into me I'm like I'm losing it
right but imagine the compound the
pressure of this is your execution
you're dying you've had your last meal
and it takes some 45 minutes to find
your vein then you're gasping for air
and now you're a second inmate looking
this looking at being aware of this
because your lawyers are filling you in
about this and you're you're looking at
a cruel I mean it's it's it's obscene in
my opinion yeah there's three drugs for
that cocktail so the first one puts you
to sleep the second one paralyzes you
and then the third causes cardiac arrest
right so if you're missing one of those
drugs in that cocktail that's pretty
important because you could be
experiencing a burning sensation and
you're fully conscious of hearing it but
you can't you can't speak you can't make
any claim so all you can do is gasp for
air and this is what they're saying that
that the that Marcel Williams jacker
afford demonstrated signs of
consciousness right and so we you know
it's is there any way to is there any
hue main way to actually execute
somebody I mean that that's really the
question yeah it seems like you know
they just fall asleep but now we're at
the point where they're not even we're
in such a hurry right so we're speaking
to the cultural problem here the the
morality problem we're such in such a
hurry to kill these people that we're
willing to expose them to an inhumane
date
is there a humane way of killing
probably not there's a gas known as
hypoxia which will actually create some
euphoric sensations before someone
passes away from oxygen deprivation but
the problem with that is if people can
just hold their breath you know yeah of
course breathing is involuntary at some
point but for minutes on end you can be
just the choosing not to breathe in that
gas so the fact that you have to
participate in your own execution yeah I
think that even that method which is the
most humane thing we can think of it
would be cruel and unusual what bothers
me the most about this story is ASA
Hutchinson who uses religious
terminology to justify it he's he's
making it seem as though is this is part
of his his moral responsibility to carry
out state state sanctioned executions
right and he uses his religious his his
Christian faith almost as a
justification as to why he's doing this
because he has a responsibility to as
governor and a responsibility to God and
once you enter that into the equation to
me Pat it really it really it doesn't
complicate the situation to me it just
exposes the hypocrisy right the level
with which these people who claim to be
Christian or whatever version of
Christianity they have they're so wet
really ready and willing to use God as a
justification for state sanctioned
killings when even if you take it that
even if you take their own religion at
their own word you know this is this is
this is something that Christians should
not be behind but Christians are the
number one people behind this and of
course we live in a secular nation so
that argument should be null and void
and it's most important when lifes are
at stake here potentially innocent lives
too because we know that 4 percent of
people on death row are actually
innocent of the crime this and this
that's the that's the last thing I'm
gonna say about this right so even if
you take this it let's start here you're
right
this religious justification that ASA
Hutchinson and other people use should
be completely outside of the
conversation it should not even come
into the conversation but they inject it
in the conversation and if you're gonna
inject it in the conversation then
people like me have to call out the
hypocrisy that of all people religious
people should Christians should be
suspicious or against the death penalty
for many reasons least of which is the
fact that you
you said the number of innocent people
who actually get executed should be
completely unacceptable whether your
religion whether your morality is based
on religion or just your own personal
morality it should be completely
unacceptable
but yet it's the it's the same people
time and time again who use it as a
justification as to why they should
carry out these executions and I think
the innocence argument is the top
argument against the death penalty
because we can have a conversation as to
whether someone deserves that or you
know are these theoretical discussions
if it does that punishment fit the crime
but if we're it executing the the wrong
people then that just goes out the
window be at the top of the list that
should be at the top of the list and
unfortunately it's not and so we've seen
a b-line streamlined execution process
in the state of Arkansas some of which
have led to what some journalists are
considering inhumane deaths